how do we start the new series
throw everything in there
[Music]
you know what i'm gonna keep the glasses
on
probably just for this one maybe again
later but
anyways hey everybody
we've reached series nine for take two
doctor who review
so this one the magician's apprentice
which i am reviewing
individually um because even though i
normally consider two parters to be a
single story when i reviewed these when
they initially
aired link in the description for the
original review if you want a comparison
i was doing them one episode at a time
so made more sense to do it in the re
in the re-review rewind
words are hard but that
resulted in something interesting
because
my brain has for the last however many
years
been filtering together magician's
apprentice which is familiar
into one story blob in my head
so what that means is watching it by
itself
and really drilling in on just this
episode on its own
there's a lot of stuff that i hadn't
noticed
now here's the thing i like this episode
i've always liked this episode
but watching it there was all kinds of
stuff that i was like okay did i just
not
notice that before or
was my like of other stuff just so great
that it completely blew past me or did i
forget
because there were a lot of little
things here and there that's like
not sure about that the big problem with
this episode and again
i'm starting negative but like i do
still like this episode so keep that in
the back your mind
we'll get there the big problem with
this episode
is that it is doing too much
and not in the recycling a whole bunch
of ideas
way that say into the dalek was doing no
no this is um
this is a case of just okay look
we are uh we have to catch up with the
doctor and clara
who aren't where we last left them um
well clara more or less is but the
doctor isn't so we got to catch up with
him we've got the cold open which
introduces davros and so we now need to
deal with that
we bring missy into the mix we've got
this whole thing
it's granted it's linked to davos but we
have this extended thing
of this snake guy hunting down the
doctor
we bring kate stewart back into the mix
that we have daleks this just it's a lot
and i suppose on the one hand that's
partly where it benefits being a
two-parter it doesn't feel
quite as crammed as it might otherwise
because it does it's not cramming in all
those
and serving up a complete story in 45
minutes so
that's where it gets away with a little
bit being a two-parter but
honestly this is a lot for one story
especially a lot to be introduced right
off the bat
but the thing is most of those
components
are really good most now
i've talked about the cold open before
because i did a ranking of what i think
are the 10 best cold opens in doctor who
this one was right up there because
it's fantastic it remembers
that in genesis of the dogs it got
established that
this war has been going on so long that
they've started using antiquated weapons
in addition to the high-tech stuff they
have
and you see that right off the bat the
hand
mines i don't know i think they're a
little bit
too weird not too weird for doctor who
but too weird for
scarro they feel they don't
feel in line with the kind of tech that
we
knew was going on in the war between the
thousand the khaled's they it
seems too whimsical so the the hand
mines i don't really
i don't really care for but they're not
really that important and what function
they serve is
still important which is basically
something that strands young davorus and
then
we've got that scene and i love
love everything about the scene between
young davorus and capaldi's doctor
all of his shouts of encouragement like
you have your chances of survival are
one in a thousand forget
the thousand focus on the one come on
tell me your name
tell me the name of the boy who isn't
gonna die today devross
my name is davros
hello and the pushing the slow
camera pushing as capaldi's face just
falls
oh man that pumped me up for the series
so much and
even knowing the resolution on this it's
still
good so props to that
absolutely then we get
into this kind of the search for the
doctor
which is one of those it's not
bad but it's weird because we saw him in
the opening
the whole sort of someone's looking for
the doctor and then it leads to
missy looking for the doctor and gets
hold of clara to help her look for the
like that sort of layer everyone looking
for the doctor and a little while before
it gets brought into the story that's
fine but it doesn't work quite as well
when we've seen him
in the cold open
so you you have two you have two
narrative ideas butting heads
he's in the cold open but then it's like
where is he he was like
and i mean i'm not saying narratively
you can't do that
and presume that he's been through
something or he's hiding for
maybe even something related to what we
saw but
it's just in terms of your the vibe you
have as an audience member you're like
well i've already seen him so now you're
trying to build an anticipation for me
to see him
see him when i've already seen him so
that's that's a little odd
i love missy's banter so much michelle
gomez
is so good and like she's really good
with clara and actually this is a thing
i keep coming back to
for all my issues with clara and they
keep coming up and they will continue to
come up
jenna coleman is really good she has
fantastic chemistry
with pretty much everybody including
missy the two of them bouncing off each
other
is great and i love missy messing with
her
that's just fun no i've not turned
good oh
she's so so so great
and then so the whole thing with the
weird snake guy
i don't really know why as much time was
sunk into that
as it was and i doubly don't know
because we have the reveal of bores
who's the other guy in the axe fight
that he's a dalek puppet and i had i
don't think i'd ever stopped and thought
about it before
and that doesn't really track like how
long has he been a doll like puppet
because if he's been one since pretty
much since the doctor
got there then what do they need this
guy
for they have they have somebody right
there
to draw him in or kidnap him or whatever
and if the if he was only changed right
now because the snake guy showed up
what was the point of that like
you you've got somebody on site do you
need a
secret operative as well i don't know
initially it just took me out because i
liked boars he doesn't do a lot here
i i thought he did more but then i
remembered a lot of what i really like
about him is from the
supporting short that aired prior to
this
and i do like him a lot he was the kind
of thing i was hoping for
in a new companion someone not from our
time a completely different vibe
i stu i do still like the bits he has
here you're going dude
to the doctor the doctor rolls in on a
tank with the guitar and okay
look let's talk about
this whole thing the hoodie the
sunglasses
the guitar
totally fine with it i know it like it
ticked off
some people some people consider it like
a big
massive shift in his character and it
kind of
is but for me it feels justified for a
couple of reasons
the first is that we kind of established
the doctor
kind well his words uh when clara says
this isn't you he's like
really not that long ago i like bow ties
and before that a long scarf this is my
party and everyone's invited
so he kind of plants the idea that he is
kind of
picking off the buffet a whole bunch of
traits across
multiple regenerations but honestly i
think that's kind of his cover story
he's
in my mind he's kind of going through a
midlife crisis
and i'm totally okay with that i
actually think it's a very cool thing
and especially knowing where he's gonna
end up by series 10 which i guess i'll
kind of preview my feelings on this
series eight the doctor is all buttoned
up you know he's got this this button-up
thing always buttoned up to the top
button
you know he he's got a couple slightly
more casual looks but you know
tight grouchy don't hug me
here he's relaxed he's kicked back he's
got the guitar
first thing he does when he sees clara
is hugger granted he's got a cover story
of uh
if you hug people they can't see your
face but
it's it's it's a midlife crisis it's him
having gone through series eight been
messed with by missy been dangled the
promise of finding gallifrey
not getting it and going hell with it
and going through his version of a
mid-life crisis
and just overdoing everything and then
we get to series 10 and it's like he's
found the balance in the middle ground
between the impulses that were leading
him to do
this and the more restrained
side that he showed early on and he
finds the balance in series 10 and i
love that journey
so uh anyways coming back to things
i mentioned kate stewart comes back i'm
going to keep an eye on this but i feel
like this might have been the start
of the dumbing down of kate stewart as a
character
i don't think it was necessarily
intentional i think it was
an unintentional byproduct of trying to
make clara look
smart so here's a big key example
missy does this thing where she freezes
all the planes
in the air and they you know clara gets
contacted gets brought in to consult
because they're trying to find the
doctor
fine cool with you so far and they don't
know what's going on they don't know why
it's happening they don't think it's an
invasion
and then clara is the one who suggests
that the planes might be used as weapons
and kate has this reaction of oh my god
it didn't occur to a
military security person
or at least someone who exists within
that world
post 9 11.
that taking over airplanes might be used
as weapons
it didn't occur to her until clara said
it
like i said i don't think the intention
is to make kate look dumb
but that's the offshoot by giving this
entire revelation
or possibility to clara in order to make
clara look smart
they pumped her up by making kate be an
idiot
and that frustrates me because i like
kate there's also kind of an odd thing
that goes on with missy i feel like
there's a little bit of rewriting a
little bit of retconning
going on or at least an attempt at it
because
missy when talking about the doctor she
only refers to him
as her friend now granted that's what
she referred to him
in um in the two-part finale
in the previous series but this one she
kind of very specifically rejects this
idea of them being
romantically linked you know this idea
of what they have is
deeper than that and then like she even
seems a little put off like ew
what which first off let me be very
clear is a
take of on their relationship i'm
totally down with i dig it
uh but it's also inconsistent with what
we saw last series
where she calls her boyfriend and
makes out with them and i mean
some of that you can chalk up to she's
just messing with him but it does create
an into
an inconsistency now that's not to say i
don't like them being kind of
oddly um flirtatious
but i i do like the confirmation
for or at least the implication that
like ooh no it's not that but it's like
but it really did look like that
last time so it it feels it feels like
moffat
realized ooh i kind of overplayed that
last series let's let's
dial it back a little which i mean i
don't object to him doing but it does
feel like a little bit of a correction
so we've got davros back julian beech
again
who's great in this part he's a great
davorus and he does a really good
he does a he does a surprisingly good
job of making this davros seem
sick and tired i don't mean like ah i'm
sick and tired but like he seems
ill and he's just kind of slumped over
like this as he talks to the doctor
[Music]
and that body language does a lot
because
like davos has always been sickly but
now like
he's able to project even through all
that makeup the idea that he's
really dying and that's
that's pretty good work right there um
always happy to see the daleks again
well almost always the first doll like
we see is this weird sort of 70s retro
looking thing
with the with blue um
bumps on it and it's not a good look
especially for the first star like we
see i don't mind that kind of dalek
showing up for like maybe
being in the background but like being
the first one prominent boom
there it is ooh and i remember wincing
first time i saw it too
that pretty much brings us up to
[Music]
the break and the cliff hangers
because there's too many there's there's
too many
cliffhanger elements at the end of the
thing because
first missy gets blasted
then clara gets blasted then they say
they're gonna destroy the tardis
then we see the doctor back in time
again looking like he's going to shoot a
kid
as too much you don't need that many
like especially it doesn't help that
each of these
are they they all fall under the
wheelhouse of what i consider to be very
lame cliffhangers
which are that these are situations
where
this is obviously not going to be what
it looks like
and it's not even a question of like oh
how will they get out of that i was like
well you showed me something that i just
know is not the case
i know missy's not dead i know clara's
not dead
i know they're not gonna destroy the
tardis and i know the doctor's not gonna
kill a kid
and so despite piling up
four cliff hangers there's no tension in
any of them
so that's a the the very end of the
episode is a bit of a
what works in here works really well at
least it does for me
i love missy and her
threatening banter with clara i love her
flirty stuff
with the doctor i do like this iteration
of the doctor
this was actually the point where i
where i'm like yeah
with capaldi because series eight there
were bits there most but i hadn't really
had that moment of
clicking with him like i'd had with
smith eggleston or tennant
i clicked with him on in this one i'm
like oh
it's a facade i get it
and that helped and so even though i can
watch
series 8 now and get that much better
than i could initially
now having seen the full arc of
capaldi's doctor
i still get really excited getting to
see this again this is quite fun
so that is the magician's apprentice
you rewatched it lately what you think
about it whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it usual stuff to do
you know what it is
like and subscribe i've got merch i've
got other
uh social media things i've got
twitter and instagram and there's
patreon which is what is paying the
bills and keeping these
lights on at the moment um
that would help out but if you can't
like share subscribe
uh the bell et cetera et cetera you
don't have to though
because um end of the day
you're the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]